all right hi everyone we are here for a
wolf language design review for 13.3 and
our subject is calculus and algebra
so
this is exciting all right long awaited
right cool okay let's take a look
line integrate
actually I think it's better to go to
the page itself
okay
so not
so what will be the traditional
I don't even understand what any of this
is yeah okay hold on
um
I like these illustrations we're getting
Roger and dim beautiful work
um so two really different cases
the scalar
you know line integral
is already there and integrate
but you can't do the vector case because
we've you know the way that that
integral is defined is to integrate each
component separately
and so you want to treat
vectors differently
right
so okay hold on
the first thing if I just say
I see if that curve is an x y space
I can just say perfectly well I mean for
example I could just say something like
integrate
um
you know x squared plus y to the fourth
x y
over
a circle for example right and that's
just fine yep
the issue is
that if I want to integrate a vector
function over the surf over the circle I
mean I hope that we're not
sort of standing on our heads to avoid
having to introduce something that will
anyway have to introduce one day
no so the the I mean integrate the
vector there just use integrate on a
vector and it will perfectly come up
with a vector so for instance a centroid
is an example of that where you really
want the listability that's the correct
definition I see
so you're saying if I say integrate x y
yeah
but particularly uninteresting in this
case because the center Edison now yeah
right but that makes perfect sense yeah
okay as opposed to you've got the
tangent vector
you're going along the Curve
looking at the tangent yes right yeah
and that's
kind of basically projecting you on to
the tangent
and so you see what component of your
vector is in the tangent Direction
so think about integrate they usually
call work integrals right where you
integrate up kind of work
along a path
well you should go positicals
that's another name yeah
and
okay I understand what this is doing
um
you should mention politicals even
though positive goal also means a
different thing
um
that's an interesting kind of worms
yeah the default orientation
yeah
this is really
it's in general it means that you
have another Vector field
defined on the region
okay
by the way is there an end version of
this does there need to be there there
will be in next in 40. yeah it's there
in its surface you can call it but we
didn't expose it because we didn't know
whether it's worth doing it right now
it's it's being used internally if you
say working position goes to something
it will call inline integrate basically
okay and then surface and and
contourintegrate so it's all possible to
verify numerically and use and integrate
basically
correct
all right content I mean surface
integrals
again I think the page is probably the
best to go to
and why do we get volume integrals
it it's already there in integrate and
we have volume yeah yeah
I see
so like in the case of line integrate
the scalar case is already there in
integrate
okay
um and the same thing here can I make a
documentation suggestion I think you
should not document that first
because I think it's confusing what what
is confusing to document the scalar case
first
I think you should document the case
first because that's why you'd use this
function yeah
it's not even obvious you should
document the scalar case well I tend to
agree with you because it it is
basically
it is a complication
because it it looks it literally is like
two different functions
but
I think Devendra and so would argue that
oh but that's what people call it that's
what they want
except people sometimes have you know
many textbooks have different names for
the scalar case and the vector case
right so like a line and a girl is one
is one case and the path integral is the
other which one is what
path is the scalar case usually
then just take the freaking scale a case
out of the main documentation
okay
just have it say it works in the notes
because people will assume you know
they'll leave the braces off it'll work
big deal because not it's it's perfectly
consistent right no
um no I don't think so well it is
concerned it's just well there's no
Vector in general there's no Vector
field that will reproduce that result
right
um right it's not the same thing as just
putting a brace around one component
right because the length of the vector
must match the ambient Dimension
definitely so how would you represent it
you'd have to have something
representing the unit tangent Vector yes
what a mess right because right right
because so right the scalar case is the
integral of the scalar times the norm of
the per you know parameterized tangent
whereas the vector case is the integral
of the dot product of the vector field
with the parameterized tangent take it
out
I really I would take it out I think
it's super confusing okay I know that
yeah
um so in this case you know we need a
different Vector field associated
uh you know on the surface which is
a normal Vector field
so it only works for hyper surfaces
um you're talking about surface
integrate yeah surface integrate now
right okay okay so the surface but then
then how do you define the normals to
the surface
same deal as your direction defining
here basically yes go down there okay
question question is it obvious that
there shouldn't be some symbolic
representation of the tangent vector
no it's I want to find the unit tangent
Vector okay here's a question I want to
find the tangent Vector at some place on
so I've got my my line
that's defined by some you know but
here's the thing in the region framework
we do not have
the the region framework does not
support oriented regions
okay
so that's not even necessarily preserved
in the Transformations done by the
region framework
and furthermore if you need to Define
orientation in general for a k
dimensional thing in n-dimensional space
what you need to do is Define an
oriented Vector space at each point
basically the tangent space
okay
and but it's not clear where we need it
I mean this is like gibbsian vector
calculus it's like a little simpler
okay but but
knowing how these things go eventually
we're going to need to define tangent
spaces
maybe but then then there should be a
use case that's strong enough no no I
understand that I'm just trying to do
defensive design so no no I I I've tried
that too you know I I was just my my
super defensive mode is to only allow
parametric regions
it's uncontroversial what it means
but I just think that the usability
suffers yeah right right but we we want
to have a default
so not all regions can be used at this
time
and I hope the messages are reasonable
say this region cannot does not have a
default orientation use what it does we
need to go okay I'll check that shot
okay but but my point is that at some
point in the future there's probably
going to be a symbolic representation of
the tangent space yeah so I think that
they're they're
which is possibly it's sorry it's just
like your XY is an element of you can
have X Y isn't it's not X Y but it's
something else there's an element of the
tangent space maybe but there's also
sort of a use case of where you
basically have some kind of vector field
Matrix field tensor field Associated to
the region yep think about sort of
different materials densities you know
all kinds of things right yep
but we don't have that at this point and
I don't think this is really like a
tailor right this point
of a dog
the the part we're just describing about
explicit tangent
yeah yeah back to Fields yeah
right I agree I mean this is important
what what you're defining here is
important because people have had to do
this sort of by hand in the past yes
no I think that this is a kind of clear
use case but but it's very limited
what's needed so when you're in a hyper
surface you can Define the tangent Space
by a normal
you know there are only two normals you
know and so that defines the orientation
of the tangent space assuming
you know our cross
across convention
listen you're talking about in a
two-dimensional surface
minus one dimensional surface in ND
there is a I see like the hypersurfaces
of like I'm sorry to be specific that
the space like hyperservices in general
relativity yeah three-dimensional and
three plus one-dimensional space right
right
okay
so your point is that the the hot wedge
product or whatever gives you an
ordinary vector-like thing if you have
an N minus one dimensional D minus one
dimensional hypersurface yes
okay
yeah I mean the cases of most interested
probably in in two-dimensional surfaces
and three-dimensional space and
three-dimensional surfaces and three
plus one-dimensional space
yeah for good measure we support you
know Curves in 2D
which are perfectly good hyper surfaces
right
now it's confusing to me when you said
hyper surface you mean maximal Dimension
I mean maximal
I don't know what they're called I don't
know what that what is that they're
called hypersurfaces if they're
Dimension n minus one they're called
hyper surfaces in for other they call
hyper surfaces of a dimension n minus
two as well
I don't know if there's a special name
but the case where there are one less
cyber surfaces
I think well I I would say that any
reasonably modern treatment of
differential geometry would say that or
geometry would say that a hyper surface
is n minus one dimensions and embedded
in N Dimensions wow
fascinating
really
okay yes I kind of agree
funky okay well I learned a new
nomenclature feature okay
um
all right so here
so I mean the surface normals
obviously defined for purposes of
lighting and things like that in other
cases right yes
and whatever we're doing here is
consistent with the conventions we're
using for defining normals for light I
mean don't polygons get to have a
special a separate normal specified for
purposes of lighting yes
and you're supporting that here I hope
not now
we could so one use one extremely useful
case is that you have a bounded space
and you think of the normal pointing
outward from it and if you want the
opposite orientation you put a minus
sign
for your expression
yeah for the thing you're integrating
right for the flux
yes yes yes exactly they're typically
called flux integrals right which by the
way you should say oh you'd say that of
course
um
and this plays nice with gradients of of
scale of fields and things like that
for making
although no I'm
that's a different thing okay never mind
I'm thinking about um
okay
what do we need to do talk about here I
mean so so obviously
so I think we I think we should still
make them experimental Stephen yeah I
agree because I think that this Regional
support will you know will will
disorientation
that we Define here
I I just I'm not super confident in its
uh
what happens if you have a
non-orientable surface
what happens if you're doing this on a
Klein bottle I mean it's fine if it's a
parametric surface this this surface
integral is perfectly well defined on
the coordinate charts or something yeah
because it has a perfectly fine normal
I see on but because you can't make a
single chart no right well you can't do
that and stay oriented consistently
oriented right
but the integral is perfectly fine
because it has
coordinate system for that right cool
lovely functions
let's go on to Contour integrate and I
would do the same there I would go to
the actual page
These are nice functions I mean how
strong are they in terms of algorithms
separate how much are they bureaucracy
and how much are they actually new
algorithms yeah so I think we also try
all kind of tricks well content degree
is different but for the other other
ones we also try to let's say apply the
Divergence Theorem to see if that helps
um we would try so there's there's a lot
of layering of methods for all three and
they've been tested against the stand
textbooks stack exchange Etc so in that
sense we're putting hundreds of it yeah
I mean I think it's good but I'm not as
confident yet you know but but I haven't
stressed in myself enough
and we try and make contact with the
classical theorems of effect analysis so
right the good news Stephen is that
they've been exposed to a lot of
textbook material and math stackaging
it's not Mathematica stack exchange yeah
that's got many more questions coming in
math exchange so it's
in that sense it's kind of real world
but I I
um I assume that the wolfen alpha folk
will once again yes
requested by them basically
okay
good looks lovely all right let's talk
about Contour thank you
um
how do you define this Contours oh God
you've got named Contours
do we have like the Bromwich contour and
things
we can expand on this
um
a lot going forward if there's you know
some
some that should be there wrong which
might be one of those but they're more
this is kind of a pretty long list
potentially
how do you visualize one of these things
in the examples I mean so I mean so
they're not too difficult to visualize
but I mean they kind of with thought of
as infinitesimal basically those holes
you know there's keyholes and all that
so under name Contours
special topic named controls I'm not
sure they visualize that easily yeah
it's not I would say yeah I agree we'll
be hard to there's more iconizer
there's like where they're getting
visualized
yeah okay that's not great doesn't give
you away what's that yeah I'm guessing
that's an epilogue there right yeah
that's a hacker it's a hack collated you
know we're visualizing I'm talking about
you've got Contour integrate
and there should be a way
of putting in complex plot
something that says
you know I don't know what you know
Contour
I don't know what it is some option that
basically says draw a Contours here just
like you can say draw grid lines on a
plot
I think it probably I think you'd
probably want to call it like complex
Contour or something like that right
because sure
right
but um
I mean okay so
but they're kind of like a named
special function if you like
the name special Contour take parameters
and whatnot
right and I mean if we have a style for
complex Contours which we should and
it's not that one there and it shouldn't
be I mean that's pretty ugly what's
happening here yeah
um
and you know what I would have thought
is really you should think about it like
grid lines
it's a you know it's a way of making
essentially canonical markings in a
contour in a complex plot
and the fact that it has name things I
think it's it's it's you know complex
plot doesn't plot curves at all
um we don't have a complex Contour plot
but we could probably have one
um don't we we do have a com don't we
have a complex Contour plot that we just
started using for visualization things
do it
well be that as it may my argument is in
a complex plot a very common thing to
want to do is just visualize you know a
contour or two
and
I think you know they should be
elegantly visualized because they are
they are writing on top of another you
know all sorts of options for the base
complex plot
just like grid lines right on top of
things
I kind of think that that doesn't make a
lot of sense for this function I think
for its own
to combine two plots would make sense
you know one that's for Curves and one
that's for you know
all right okay
but matender Quest is still a packaging
problem Stephen which I'm thinking about
sort of I don't think it will work Roger
I don't think it'll work and I'll tell
you why because I think these little
wiggle woggles around here okay it
depends on many things this is really
diagrammatic right because that actually
is a microscopic deviation there yes
right so this is really diagrammatic
this is not a plotted curve in the
complex plane
this is a diagrammatically it's like an
axis annotation
yeah but it's
but it really has complex plot has
nothing to do with curves in its plot
particularly
I know but what I'm saying is don't
think of this as a curve think about it
as a marking like a grid line
that indicates a region of the plot
because I think I I just don't think I
think it's diagrammatic not
you know
I mean yes you could imagine a contour
that was carefully woven but that's not
what people are going to do typically
they're going to want a named Contour
that is just one of the standard
semicircles avoiding poles things like
this
yes
but that's what I'm thinking that we
could have sort of in such a
you know things that actually plots
curves because you don't necessarily
want the function the complex plot is
for it's always colors that's the whole
planet here's another analogy okay like
the disembodied axis functionality
this is kind of a bit like that
throw a disembodied
you know
yes you're thinking of it like a new
primitive type thing yeah but it's in
it's very expensive for us to add New
Primitives I know
um
you know and most people really don't
care
I mean I I think it should be an option
to complex plot because I think that's
where it's always going to get used
foreign
that seems like such incredibly hackery
okay well fine I mean that the
I'm worried that if you just have it be
a separate function
um no I think it's interesting to plot
Curves in the complex plane irrespective
okay yeah I agree with you you know and
so I you know I think that that's
valuable irrespective
um and you don't always want all these
you know complex plot background stuff
you know often you don't care at one bit
I mean it's it's interesting that we can
now do it it's insightful and everything
but
but traditionally people never did it
because they only could do the curves
I understand
ah I think we need to think some more
but but I agree with you we need an
easier way we need an easy way to
visualize those
right we sort of disconnected from our
live stream audience but anyway we can
um
these are also rather ugly if you've got
can we get a little bit of graphic
design on this on this black
yeah I mean
right now it's using our Graphics
primitive and black
well I think given that we'll I mean
I know maybe Tim can do better but right
given that
these things right anytime you have a
zero or a pole you're going to use the
entire rainbow in the background I don't
know that black is in fact such a bad
choice maybe it's slightly grayed I
don't know okay
say I know that I will try and do that
okay but we need to fix I mean I really
want to come up with a better scheme
this is like something that expands it
into graphics
you know
or something but it's just
um what happens
this is a physics moment I mean in in um
uh
usually you have you know p squared
minus I Epsilon to specify in the
function itself to specify the routing
around a poll yes
in a way that's what it's doing the
those happen or they're kind of taking
the Epsilon into account and then
setting them to zero so you're kind of
getting rid of the
The Singularity if that's what you mean
I mean you're going around it but you're
not
hitting the infinity
that each
so are you specifying at each point
whether you're going above or below the
singularity I mean yes okay so if you
read the specification in there
yes exactly either go above below
um
I think it's mildly unfortunate that
there's no way to specify that in the
function
in the function
right in physics the common convention
is that the function is one over p
squared minus I Epsilon
and then you're simply integrating on
the real line
which takes it right which takes you one
above and one below right and you you
can use a minus sign to flip them and
then you'll add and subtract such
combinations to when you want the you
know the purely forward or purely
backward propagator
um as as we say in the physics land so I
mean it's a little
I mean right you'd need a special
right you'd need a special variable a
way to specify which variable is Epsilon
and then some canonical way to decompose
the input I'm not sure that's actually
going to be more useful and or easier in
practice Yeah I think I just think it's
worth looking at that physics convention
because
I mean these things where it's sort of a
you know I'm not thrilled with these
things where
kind of like it almost feels like they
should turn into associations and then
it's you know more complicated stuff
um
let's see
so and I you know for something like an
investor plus transform don't you need
the Bromwich Contour thing which goes
yes but that's easy because you can just
just use a vertical line for that
infinite line we could document that
separately but we have examples where we
just call in and to be honest with you
sometimes we just find inverse Laplace
transform is so optimized for those that
we might even call it internally
because if you got exactly right I got
it I got it yeah so you got a rational
function you'd never get anywhere with
uh you know kind of
a non-built-in method
right yes I understand this upper
semicircle how far does it go does it go
to Infinity in both directions yes
essentially yes yes
says capital r goes to infinite and
Epsilon goes to zero kind of thing
but so why are these pictures
showing this is why I'm telling you you
have to have something which is just
kind of a marker like an axis because
this is really going to Infinity you
can't actually draw it
see what I'm saying
okay okay but you see my point that this
really isn't going to Infinity yeah
it's really a decoration it is a
decoration
right which is why I think it should be
part of the complex plot story not part
of a separate thing because if it's part
of a separate thing you have to specify
you know if you change the range of the
of the complex plot
you're going to you know mess up the
decoration
I really think that we need to think
some more about that but I I kind of
yeah
fine I mean I think we can plot to
Infinity for complex plot but how the
heck you do
you know epilogue on complex plot with
infinities
because it's the upper half circle
um
and maybe you'd want it to become dashed
at some point or something right to
suggest that it's
ainaura
I think we have to do it I think of
course yeah I don't think we're gonna
solve it right now
I agree with Roger we're not going to
instantaneously solve this problem
okay yeah fair enough all right I'm
arguing for this being a decoration but
I might be wrong
okay let's I think we have to come back
to that okay fine
okay so we can trivially verify yes here
we go
cool it's the first example yes
um
and uh
yeah very nice
yeah we've gone to all lens to test all
two or three full textbooks math
exchange for example if I do the
following if I say
this thing if I just do one of a z uh
you might need to Define reg this is
why do you do it like this why don't you
just say Z element to regular polygon
you're not using reg a second time
okay I noted that but please don't do
that I mean it's just well he might be
using it in the in the icon now which is
a different problem we need to I mean
look so
by all means tell us when you find
something but I haven't worked through
the examples examples need some it just
crashed
oh great clashed what version
uh
I don't think too much that's pretty
Fresh So as fresh as I have
crashed
I tried yes
well the the danger of using the
Prototype build well also it's my my
perfect you know
divining Rod so to speak exactly
I bet if I try with the Pentagon it
won't crash
uh
oh I gotta crushed you yeah okay all
right fine
garage Cuts what on Earth do we do with
barge Cuts well actually the see if you
think about the counter integral is just
a real integral in some sense so you can
always in the end use
integrate
I mean because our Branch cuts are set
they are defined predefined I see
I mean the thing is we think of the
content integral as being the complex
Planet but really it's just a
like a riemann's still there's a lot of
integral so in the worst case we just do
that but that seems to help oh yeah
also counters don't need to be closed at
all a counter integral
perfectly well defined for an open
Contour yep it's also perfectly well
defined for a non-merromorphic function
yes essential singularities and all
kinds of things
Stephen you just just no residue theorem
and also underneath it to use the N
counterintegrate so we have kind of some
consistency between integrate and
integrate when you have inexact input so
we can check things
screw
very nice so does I'm sorry does it have
is it just using koshy's theorem you
know if it notices like in this case
does it just check to see the poles
inside the region yes and it'll use
residue sum which we introduced some
time ago and that will use the residue
so basically if you're built up from
residue to residue some residual sum to
Contour integrate so it's just layer on
layer building up
and the orientation is provided by the
koshy theorem because that only holds if
you're
Contours oriented correctly so in a way
we have escaped in that case we don't
need orientation at all
well
because your residue theorem only works
if you
you're doing sum of residues right but
sure that will only work if the Contour
integration is kind of correct so we
almost by default we get the correct
orientation for the metamorphic case
wait a minute so you're saying every
Contour is counterclockwise in some
sense well yes that's correct I think
that no I no there's things you haven't
thought through here they're complicated
poly you can Define polygons which have
very different orientation rules than
cautious rules for what's inside and
what's not what happens with a bow tie
well I mean it should be
well you we
if you if you just give a line that is a
bow tie it will do the right should do
the right thing
okay
by the way these these lines don't look
very counterclockwise up at the top here
no those are curves which has you see
that it describes what the default
orientation is depending on
parametrization oh I see
this is the part I'm less you know
that's why I'm a bit
um right so okay so a contour integral
usually is around a contour but for a
region you are assuming it's around the
boundary of the region or boundary is
plural as a convenience because it's
good for user good for us to allow that
because we don't have as many concerned
about whether that's consistent
yes I agree with them totally absolutely
okay fine so you guys will look at it
but these cases these named cases are
clearly okay yes discs in different
places and things like that
yeah and if you want the opposite
orientation you use a minus sign for
your integrand
yeah if you want it for all of them but
what if you want some it rotating around
it well you can always patch okay so you
can always give a bunch of Curves right
there's always a workaround it might not
be as convenient as you want it but
there is a counterclockwise how is the
clockwise Circle specified
well we as a don't change the
orientation of the curve you if you want
to do integrate clockwise around a
circle you put a minus sign around your
function no I understand that but if you
have some positively
rotating you know some circles that you
want to rotate you know some poles you
want to go around positively some of you
want to go around negatively I don't
know whether you ever want to do that
I've never wanted to do that but I can
remember
if you've thought of a direction option
but it just looks too risky and I
totally resulted that it's not worth
going to write now what you've covered
is kind of the ground enough we have
broken it through the next layer of
complex analysis you like you know
that's all fine I also looking forward
to sort of hear back from people I think
that this makes them
I think that they address a lot of use
cases and I'm sure users are going to
tell us we like this too and we would
like to hear from them yeah all right
fine
achieving oberhettinger
yes so overheading there was a junior
kid on the Bateman project well kid I
mean PhD
um
that was the people who did the um I
remember that right right but Ober
Hettinger went on to spend the rest of
his life on integral transforms okay
okay fine so much more on that so he was
you know there was only two volumes some
integral transforms in debateman Project
so he wanted to do it right
cool I don't really know a
characterization of what's different
between you know doing integrals in
general and doing integral transforms as
in
other
radically different methods for doing
integral transforms as compared to
generic integrals
one thing we use quite a lot over here
is to verify particularly things like
series coefficient and sum so you try
and work out
the series coefficient for something and
then use
you try and find the integral of that
and then sum it so that seems to be one
technique so I mean the techniques are
much deeper because there's more special
class and overrating is just a very
difficult collection so it took some
time to check things so we are just
being a very final check and we'll have
everything out for the release bit yeah
okay did we fix this horrifying thing
about these stupid things well God this
drives me
this oh you now have itai here why don't
you guys talk me amongst each other so
uh I mean I I believe we came up with a
design about a year ago and we we need
to find somebody to actually Implement
said design
um maybe maybe when Carlo is done with
the with the audio GUI he
he could do this or no no no no
okay let's figure out how to get it done
we really need to get it done okay
whatever that did by the way was
incredibly weird
of um what did what do oh it had some
crazy thing that said formatting I was I
just copied that and it went into a
conniption for a while
could be prototype builds yeah it could
be
okay but so what you've done here
is dramatically simplified I see
generalized fibonacci-like things
no so the general class is a constant
coefficient single equations
or constant coefficient systems of
equations
within home you know in the
inhomogeneous case in particular
is what has huge Improvement and that
sad to say but it wouldn't surprise me
if that's 90 of what people use
right
okay nice
okay should we move on to algebra
okay very nice work on calculus there
thank you okay algebra
finite Fields Long awaited
okay
tell us at the guide page let's just see
what we've got here
um
I would go to the finite field reference
page test you can go to the guide page
too but the finite field reference page
is one I feel I've worked through
a lot
oh I haven't seen consideration of the
paycheck that looks really pretty
um
what happened there oh crap oh no no
nothing no nothing that's just future
this the future right stuff is literally
future so in the next release find out
that the um the general Prime power
Fields will be supported in the linear
algebra under solvers as well
right now it's supported in the
polynomial functions Beyond arithmetic
I assume pilot feel just of P gives gfp
Adam do you have to give one or just
no you have to give one I yeah we can we
can we can make that yeah
just work because that's going to be gf2
is really common
oh okay
all right let's see how this is supposed
to work we've had designs for this at
different times over the last
35 years
that's a bit funky if I might say so
that is what of the appearance of these
things
okay
please don't make there have to be a one
though that's really goofy
sorry
I think it would also be nice isn't it I
mean don't doesn't always say GF such
and such or does one not
um
[Laughter]
both those standards exist Stephen and I
I think people have moved on to Golden
finite fields in general
more often than than Galway feels
all right
but I mean if one was writing it as a
field one would say what one would say F
sub five or one say gf5
F sub five
then why isn't that what this shows F
sub five rather than this whole bloggle
thing here
why don't we have something where where
fundamentally it looks more like the
math notation
I see well I mean it uh right I mean the
in in a typical case and I suppose this
isn't necessarily A blocker but right in
a typical case right the characteristic
is not five it's you know something with
500 000 digits or some such or at least
500 digits
um and you know it seems a bit more
natural to start abbreviating
abbreviating such things in a summary
box than in uh and something that just
looks like f of subscript but enough I I
agree but I don't I think what what I'm
suggesting is that what this looks like
is maybe finite field and then what's
what appears here is f superscript 5
over F sub five or whatever it is and
then it can be F sub five dot dot dot
whatever just so visually you see finite
field okay great you know roughly oh
that's the app you're talking about oh
yeah yeah absolutely that's an easy fix
well I'm I'm just saying then you could
leave off all this stuff here and you
could put that under the plus sign
just say finite field plus and then this
just oh so then the whole thing is a
little smaller yeah
interesting yeah
um
I mean that's that's just changing the
the graphic will adapt to its objects
yeah I don't think we have any precedent
for just the icon with no I know we
don't I'm just so sorry about that but I
mean I think that's I think it would be
a good thing to do here because there is
a standard math notation which you might
as well use
okay I can I'll well I will I will play
around with it uh I I won't I won't
promise that this is instantly
implemented
okay but obviously you should have lied
it if there are lots of digits on the
five so to speak right and I don't know
if there are any examples here but you
know I certainly tested it with you know
hundreds of digits and and and whatnot
so yeah that are some of the following
food page
there are some examples with slog Primes
no one come on come on please please
let's have a proper message here
I promise
no it's it's a strange one you should
should say it's not a primer I I guess
yeah that must be a type or something it
just looks like a wrong message
and what's that eye doing there is that
that I was that that's the link to the
to the I know I know I know but why is
it blue
because that's the color you picked
after looking at multiple options okay
good fine I believe you by the way I
just want to remind you that because
we're now feeding error messages back to
llms
they matter more
yeah
there's clearly some build issued there
because of the pinking there so
right I'm just I'm just commenting that
error messages the text of error
messages is being fed back to llms when
evaluation fails
I think so for it to know that it's not
a prime is very useful to it not only to
the humans but to the to the AIS as well
okay so anyway this is I don't know it's
501 a prime I have no idea just do next
prime of 500 or
or prime of 500.
okay great
all right there we go okay so now I'm
saying this number
is the fifth element of that
right
and
I don't understand when you go
naive question if I do the this field
here
ah okay super naive question oh look at
that I mean you're doing exactly this
503 I don't even know what that what
what would that how would that be
notated as an F thing
how do you notate I mean when it's GF
it's GF 503 cubed
right but what would it be
F sub you know a sub P to this power D
it's usually that's why okay okay fine
so it looks just like this okay yeah
I think okay question how do you number
the elements which is The Fifth Element
so to speak and uh so so these are
digits in a system
uh in in a system mod P
so or in in the base p
so well right there are two possible
numberings because there's the
polynomial and exponential
so if you look here
zero and one are special
and then the enumeration is given below
for the two representations well that's
a new thing I mean I do think
structuring these these details sections
is a reasonable idea
yeah but I think you need subsections
here
yeah I was trying to avoid death because
we don't have it yeah I know but I think
we're gonna have to have it
um
so so you're telling me okay for for gfp
these are both equivalents and they just
number the integers correct
yes
okay but when it's a Prime power field
then these are two different
representations
oh no actually there are different
different stations for for for for Prime
fields too
why how I mean so the first one of the
astronautical representation go ahead
so the first one is is the natural
numerical representation the polynomial
and the exponential would be exponents
of affinity element
or exponents of previous element minus
one actually two so I understand if the
Primitive element is just
you know
or exponentials of a prone development
exponential so the previous element
below five would be like two yeah and
these are powers of two
minus one
okay
so
if I was just doing this
and by the way I mean in in you know we
have all these cases like I don't know
shift changes the sequences or something
where we want to have things
well I don't know that might not be a
good example but but how do I get this
and unpack it
what happens if I say normal of that
no what what do you mean attack it
well I want the integer out I want the
at least for the case of gfp I want to
be able to get the integer out
uh so for for the gfp you you just say
that or information of that index or
that
and the property index
oh yeah
right
okay
dude I know the finite Fields have sub
values what about the finite field
elements do they have string sub values
yeah so so the playing field elements
have things about Fields actually don't
because
they make elements that way because
they're requirements here
so how do I find the the characteristic
say characteristic and we will get
characteristic property
so information or
uh or for the field for the field you
have to have information field comma
characteristic
okay but if I just say
is that is the form that I think it's in
yeah it is it is this is just an
appearance of this right so if I say
input form percent one
oh
that's what it is
because it computed a it's competitive
an irreducible polynomial for you
yeah
okay
okay so now if I take this
thing here and with some precedence
okay so if I if I wanted to know
what is it the multiplicative order
what do we what do we call that
multiplicative order what's up
that's cool oh no wait a minute what
does it just do
I should be able to say what's the
multiplicative order of that element in
that finite field is that not correct
yeah it knows if I have feel so you
don't have to give the the fine field
Finance field is inside the element
I understand but so it shouldn't be
giving that carrot either right
right until we add a single argument
usage to the ref page and the futureize
it right that that's where that
character
I know I know I know I know I know I'm
just saying we should eat the carrot so
to speak or whatever one does yes
okay but I like the fact that it works
for multiplicative order here
so
what other kinds of functions work on
this
so I assume I can have these as
coefficients in a um so if I say
you know Factor
that's very cool
let's talk about the appearance of this
thing and that rather ugly plus sign
okay well have you tried first you
should try clicking on the plus sign
and see why it's there no I think that's
magnificent but I mean okay oh it's the
specific appearance of the plus sign is
yeah well I just used the plus same plus
sign that we use in summary boxes now if
if if design has some other plus sign to
give me
I'm I'm happy to use that so now those
angle brackets there
they're not right they're not really
there
yeah I wonder if they should be Gray
um
probably
yes I mean I as an implementation matter
it's probably better to just add some
opacity right so that yeah okay fine if
you change font color but yeah right
okay now in terms of this
why are using angle brackets is that a
standard notation for finite field
elements
uh I couldn't find a really standard
notation and so
um
people do sometimes use angle brackets
in when discussing finite Fields but
nothing that looks specifically like
this
um but this seem maybe we need a
different I think that there's a little
bit different conventions like
often you might just use some kind of
symbol like Alpha that I used in intro
there in the finite field page right and
then the subscript is like which one of
them so you can tell them apart they're
two different that kind of a bit silly
because the alpha is kind of a waste it
absolutely is a waste of just saying
that that's that's kind of a convention
and I think
that I agree with you we don't want that
here so that's I'm not advocating that
particularly yeah
um
let me think
I wonder what um
so people either use just a number
I see some I don't know you I mean you
kind of want the number but you want to
know it's not like a number
I know
um
well what could we do here
that
kind of is a
because I mean we we don't have to have
you know we could
what kind of decoration could we
consider
because I mean
okay possibility okay let me try this
is that a possibility
and then with a subscript outside the
frame or inside the frame or
thinking okay so hold up
I admit that that's
right superscript no I just need
subscript
well you'll need superscript if you want
the 503 but yes yeah I know that's what
I just want to do
who
okay here's my suggestion here's my
suggestion we should really get somebody
from design here
um
this isn't quite right but something
like this
with the plus sign integrated in here
actually I would put the plus sign on
the right right of that
now you want it on the left because so
that if you then want to close it you
don't need to move the mouse
okay I trade both positions and I
realized my mistake yeah that's a that's
a classic ux mistake
that's not quite right but
I mean maybe it's uh
maybe it's just me but the angle
brackets feel very mathy to me and this
doesn't feel very mathy and
so I have to say this doesn't strike me
like
the direct the correct direction I don't
know how other people feel
um where do I put this here
how do I put this
anybody
well I mean if you want to put it in the
LCC folder you can oh and I'll find it
okay okay
I agree that it isn't okay okay
I just don't like all the decorativeness
okay so here let's let's try taking this
thing here is any way I can replace
these things by a lighter gray angle
bracket
uh
um
maybe I'll try to create something
quickly and send it to you okay I mean
maybe is is there an angle bracket
yeah I mean I could just do that okay
okay
so
in this expression
let's say I mean I'll just make one of
these you know
angle bracket
118.
Plus
um anybody know how to turn this into
uh
let's see
um
and we'll know how to turn this into
something which has some
um
need subscripts
yeah I want to make the actual angle
bracket itself
yeah I'm sure if I say style this thing
black
and style this thing
oh there we go
I'll put second okay
yeah that font size I can't really see
any color difference but not only yes
you can you can because well I I can't
see it on my screen you maybe I'll do
the wrong thing you're looking at the
wrong thing it's the second it's the
last oh it's the second one yeah okay
this looks a lot better
okay I mean that's super easy to
implement
and and right so you use gray level 0.7
that's a pretty that's a pretty common
level we use I mean okay but then and
then for this subscript
I think you need to integrate the plus
sign into this with some kind of gray
background for the whole thing or
something
you can get somebody from design here
otherwise we can't we see if we can find
maybe Jeremy again
I'll grab them
we'll come back to this
um
here's the field characteristic
oh it supports it supports integers half
integer the half
so some elements have square roots and
some elements and all elements have
these routes but other roots are are to
compute
okay so this one here
are you saying it's about no no it's not
it's power the power of the element so
so you need to take the element okay
so that that's the square root of that
or whatever Keith root
that will be so five five or three and
one
really
the five of these rules of five is five
oh because it's
yeah
some larger number that's not an integer
in the field
and which field
oh the the five so stress some index
larger than 503
index index not not the prime
here
just tell me um know the next one next
one of yeah make this election remember
one two three four
something
you use uh 503 change that one-third
back to one over 503.
yeah so now it's different
well I understand why this didn't just
reduce it anyway because it's that
number is going to wrap around in the
finite field isn't it yeah so
so why doesn't that reduce right now uh
well I don't think I don't think that's
big enough right because it needs to be
503 cubed what does that number compare
with 503 cubed okay that reduces yes
okay I got it
okay
by the way we do need to worry about how
this looks relative to base form
right and one of the reasons we I mean
we I did have an earlier prototype with
just a subscript and everybody's first
reaction was well that looks just like
base form and so angle brackets still
mathy but clearly not base form
comment from Quantum our live stream
that saying universities sometimes at a
bar above the numbers
of convention you guys have seen
number three that's maybe it will look
good
um
I I do really think we should look some
more for this I I don't I just it's not
something I would know because I
you know it's one of the ugly things
about finite Fields is what you call the
elements and you usually hope you don't
have to name them
right
yes people often start out with let
Alpha be an element of blah and then do
everything in terms of alpha right so
they they just avoid the issue but we
can't do that
right Jeremy we're we're working on
finite fields
numbers mod something or other Etc
um and uh
right now we have this rather ugly
creature
with us yeah
you're very very very faint oh there we
go yeah
um
okay so we're planning to at least we
don't know whether the angle brackets
are the right notation
what is this
it's a number in a finite field so it's
a number like clock arithmetic like mod
12 or something yeah
um this particular case mod 503 to the
third power
okay
um
and
why is that plus oh
boy so it has a nested
okay all right so
what we've been proposing down here
is just to gray down the brackets
although
let me just um
well now let's put the subscript in
there
are they likely to be the same base in a
given equation yes okay it will have to
be the same base okay
is that a true statement guys that
they'd never be not in the same base
yeah
if it's supposed to be useful
in fact I'm not even sure if we support
the same base but different
representations but we convert them
automatically if you try to do something
with it okay
and I I've got the Sorting wrong here
but that's okay
now the question is is that enough I
mean that that looks a lot better than
you know we can go slightly
still looking reasonable
the black is not looking so reasonable
now this here
we could go
oops
yeah
oh Style
that looks kind of terrible
yeah
um
and we've also got to get that plus sign
in there somehow
um
that's absolutely invisible
why is it so invisible maybe because
there's something
well the plus sign could be bigger
and that whole thing could be clickable
right
um I mean I I'd rather not do that
because then you can't access any of the
pieces in there if you if right if you
want to just copy out the base
but it is very redundant that we're
having to repeat
I mean I think this looks really ugly
with all the pluses there and I'm
worried that it it suggests addition you
know
you know if we had the whole thing be
clickable then then it tries to
complaint about moving your mouse if you
click it twice wouldn't be an issue
anymore
that's true
um
what about the double Chevron that's the
opener cell opener inline cell opener
where would you put it it'd be at the
end
that'd be fine I mean a small one of
those be a fine
just a shame that these are so
repetitive
and
yeah I mean okay is there any other
notation and any other kind of wrapping
if we're going to wrap these numbers in
something this is deemed not mathy
enough
so let's just see
um
there's no weird thing with these for
example
let's look at ours
boy what's going on with pallets in this
prototype build just crazy
by the way uh jumping back to the
Chevron idea I think it would be better
to put the Chevron on the left and make
it a down Chevron like we do with code
assist
okay
okay let's take a look at our bracket
choices here
um where are our brackets
they're gonna
yeah look there they are
right so obviously some of those right
floor ceiling are not usable no not a
full floor ceiling but but a a short
floor ceiling would be usable at the
bottom of the number
at the bottom of the number like
something like this
just underneath the two sides of the
number
that will be usable
mm-hmm
um
I'm not sure what else from there is
usable
and those are all binary operators those
that's all not going to be useful
two three zero e
H what why isn't this
that's incredibly ugly and this font
it's it's important
to show cell expression
so slow something is really really
broken in this front end
well okay maybe maybe if I zoomed in
maybe maybe that's what it actually is
here yeah I think it is what it actually
is here that's not what I thought it was
okay
and I'll can you do show cell expression
on that uh cell
right so it doesn't have a long name
which means it's pulling in whatever
system font it can find this in rather
than using one of our fonts yeah that's
what I would expect
what do we want to communicate in a you
know a finite field
what's its visual what what visual
metaphor I mean other than an alpha
which is used for these things
what's the right visual thing to
communicate to these
given that they all have to have this
stupid subscript
and I assume the subscript is the right
place to put that
I think so
uh I think I think right I mean it is
um
yeah that that is I think pretty
standard
yeah
um
I mean off right obviously it'll often
just be in textbooks just the P right
but it'll
I mean often you set it up in context
and you don't show it
uh well for sure we should go down to
smaller font size for that subscript
okay
and I don't know whether that background
is helping or hurting it's probably
hurting
let's get rid of that background
well it helps that the gray plus sign
isn't oh it's gone now
yeah if that was a down Chevron I think
it'd look decent okay what would that be
to make a down Chevron
Chevron
oh yeah I really wish John were here so
you could tell me the secret code to get
the actual official code assist down
Chevron but uh
um
okay looked a lot better than it
did before
I mean obviously we
think it's reasonable Now is it going to
have a mouse over that says find that
field element blah blah blah
it should presumably
you mean the whole thing or yeah I'm
thinking yes yes
okay
all right but we can come up with no
better visual metaphor than the angle
brackets
Roger anybody
the only thing that I was thinking of
whether one always need the subs you
know to know what field it's in
oh that's a mouse over thing
I think we should put it in which that
would be small
I think we'll survive putting it in
there I mean but we we do need to align
it quite quickly if it's more than four
characters long we probably need to
alight it
okay
even three characters I mean you know
you know you really care about the field
uh here's a question
if it's an enlightened thing do we want
to have a character at the beginning dot
dot dot character at the end is it
useful to know
what what what do what I've done is once
it grows beyond and I think my limit is
much higher like 20 but
um you know it just says P you know P to
the K and then if you want to see the
details you click the plus sign and you
have the full finite field element for
full finite field object there that you
can get anything
I would not go to Pizza care I think
that's very bizarre because there'll be
a lot of other K's that somebody has and
you have no idea that your K isn't
you know killing another K so to speak
conceptually so to speak yeah actually
all right
I think the case always stays stays the
actual number we don't expect a lot of
response there right so the piece stays
uh you know becomes becomes sympathy but
it shouldn't because there might be a p
in your expression it's really not a
good idea let's just give the damn
number and and you know with dot dot
dots now my only question to you guys is
is it useful to see beginning and end is
the end potentially useful because it
might tell you something about well I
mean clearly it's never an even number
do anything you could easily tell by by
the end yeah I mean with large primes no
there's nothing you can tell I know I
suppose I should defer to Adam but as
far as I know there's nothing you can
tell by the last few digits of a large
Prime well it's whether it's in the form
six n plus one or six n minus one right
with few first digits few less digits
and the number of digits missing it's
informative since you see the size of
the of the number
right
well I think if we give the number of
digits missing we're going to get super
confused
I think we should just give
you know a couple of digits at the
beginning dot dot well if you don't
think the digits at the end are useful
then we should just give a you know a
couple of two or three digits at the
beginning
okay
um
okay we have anything else to discuss I
mean again I'm not thrilled with the
fact that we don't have a notation
for finite fields
that is you know that's somehow more
suggestive because we're we're you know
we've had a we've done a good job over
the years of inventing notations that
are suggested for things
and this seems like a bit of a wimp out
that we're not coming up with anything
here
I mean I think I have seen angle
brackets for some
in the past
um
well well the good thing is that the
styling is almost entirely in the style
sheet so if we come up with something
better later we can always update the
yeah I know but but we don't want to
um
okay
all right well lovely so I think that's
everything we need to join me for yeah
I'm gonna have to leave
unfortunately
okay well then we'll have to schedule
some more yeah I think we need one more
round on this maybe an hour
or maybe less
oh wow solve works for this
uh not yet
next release yes
and and the way you'll specify the field
is what
and solve
uh so instead of real sorry and
complexes you you say you give the field
finite field
yeah
what do you do for Factor
do you say uh so it's I I do the fields
pretty of course coefficients or
extension goes to f
how do you specify the coffee the field
something to do is the field
but this isn't an extension so right no
I understand well if you do integer
coefficients and and then put extension
goes to a f that that also works and
it's it's sort of useful you can
uh you consider those integers as
elements of the field and Factor over
this field does it have reasonable
messages when you combine finite field
elements with with plane integers does
it does it so if you combine with plain
integers it's it it just includes the
integers in the field without a message
if you combine with something you cannot
include them in the field then it gives
an error message
how do you uh sorry this is naive
question but how do you combine I mean
it's something that isn't just you know
gfp how do you combine the integer into
the field
uh so the integer you take is model
appear and and and
so that's fine
the queue or something no you you take
it not p and then include in the field
the field every every finite field
contains uniquely a copy of zp
so so the integers are considered
elements of zp okay I guess it I get it
I got it I got it and so if it's but if
the field was P to the Q it would have
more copies of that but you just put
this into the canonical first first one
is that correct first one yeah yes yes
so it's or it's just integer times
the one in the field
right right
so I have a question here which is I
mean in terms of other more exotic
functions like
um
you know uh primitive like the things
for for shift Rogers to sequences
which are very finite Fieldy
um
I mean presumably it's a nice example
you can you can show with with Jeff two
you can show a nice fractal
how do I do this let me just do this
so I say finite
field
two except it has to be two comma one
and then I want X plus one like this
and then I want to take that
to the power t
and I want to take the expand of that
I want to do
a coefficient list which presumably will
work
that and then oops comma X
oh what the hell is this okay
table
T comma 20.
why is this taking on to real time okay
let me make now
a um
why is that
okay column
lovely
well if it didn't if it lined up
properly actually if I want to make a
grid here
can I make it good I don't know if I can
make good
oh isn't that lovely
that's a cute example for you it's a
very nice yeah
um
great could you send it go to us somehow
for
I mean you can do it with other
modulee and other
it's very nice thanks
I recommend also well let's see what
would happen if I tried to do it
um
1 over X Plus x times that does that
work
no well coefficient at least likes
doesn't like the denominators
denominators
see
now this
uh
why is that not
that's not as beautiful as it could be
well anyway
that looks beautiful if you render it
correctly
um
okay
so okay well
so all of these things what about gcd
does gcd make any sense
what about other null theoretic
functions
so gcdlcm that it's a field so so so it
doesn't make sense yeah other
aren't there things with Mobius
functions and so on that makes what
about what about the duration they have
don't they make sense like Zeta
functions with you know the rich life
functions with dirichlet character you
know the characters in the rich life
series aren't they finite field thingies
can't you have L Series over finite
fields
let me know correctly right
I mean you know that to be nonsense or
do you not know either way I don't know
okay I'm pretty sure you can't because
I'm pretty sure remember the definition
of an L function
has that that the character thing and
the elf and the L function definition
right and I'm pretty sure that you know
it's minus one whatever yeah
I think it's I think it makes sense I
think you should ask um
Johnson
probably Charles yeah
I think you should go on a hunt for some
other
um
I'm trying to think whether the cellular
automaton function whether there's
things there
okay here we go
yeah I'm pretty certain that this is a
way
kaiban is a is a dirichlet character
yeah module okay the possible the
original characters module okay
especified by an index blah blah blah
I'm pretty sure this is highly related
I I don't know for sure but it looks
related
um what other number Theory functions
are relevant to this
I'm not sure is related but there's
these uh
elliptic hyper elliptic curves which
having studied over finite Fields so I
think I'm all right that's right I mean
the discrete logarithms I mean that's
kind of I I know the literature they'll
pass down to item at some point okay but
what about what about integer
factorization
does that make any sense in a finite
field
[Music]
so so you don't have factorization there
right
um
doesn't make any sense
what exactly is created that's that
might be something that that yeah
primitive root must make sense
it must make sense it's the same
creature isn't it
yeah a modular inverse surely makes
sense doesn't it
power mode obviously well power mod
the third argument of power mod probably
okay here's a question is mod capable of
taking as a second argument some kind of
field
uh what would it do
it would reduce the thing and that will
I it would reduce it don't just put the
integer in the field or yeah what you
what you just explained was was the
thing you were doing
oh okay yeah it's good I mean I don't
know that it makes sense but I'm just
suggesting that might be useful yeah at
least for integers it's you know model
works for for complex numbers and I
think it's not on not a rational number
what's yeah maybe it's not a good idea I
don't know
um
all right
uh well fine this is looking great I
mean
and and then linear algebra you say is
coming is coming here
and okay well next time we've got a
small amount to do here I don't think
this is probably not
oh boy uh this is gonna be a mess is
this real the structural matrices thing
is this a big is this yeah no no it's
just some of you requested this target
structure where you know you can request
a particular kind of output either dense
or structured or sparse it's I think you
request like maybe probably last release
and we've done it now that's all okay so
this is a substantial build out or is
this
well we've had there are several new
structured Matrix types I mean it's not
okay fine right let's pick this up next
time
um also while we're at it look at the
new formatting and finite fields and um
otherwise looking good
thanks good stuff well well done thank
you all soon